you weren't in the country when these
sniper killings took place in Washington
in october two thousand two and you came
back and weren't aware really of the
impact this had made and I'm wondering
what drew you to this story many years
later and convinced you that this could
be a film I was looking for a subject to
make a fast and furious film and I stump
stumble upon the blurb that described
the Beltway sniper explaining that it it
was the perpetrator the perpetrator
where father and son team that were
actually father and son of adoption and
that that image immediately like jumped
at me and and I saw the potential I saw
how by telling the story fruitful for
that that small angle that intimate
angle we you know we could the whole
story will could have like a certain
venir an allegory about you know the
education of violence well Alex
approached me with the idea which which
I found hugely intimidating because of
you know I grew up on East Coast and the
cultural resonance was sort of very in
my head at all times and so the the idea
of being able to tell a story sort of
around and behind the headlines was was
very appealing but the the process of
actually getting around those headlines
and trying to find a private story sort
of that looked at the the the moments
that were so intimate between these two
people that they were even hypothetical
at some points you know that the idea
that that you could tell a story about
them without necessarily seeing with
only implying the the sort of the parts
that everyone knew whose exciting but
but it's it sounded hard it sounded
super challenging first and foremost it
was very important that that we gathered
all the fact that we could and so we did
some extensive research and on you know
add access to the court document and
on the police record the medical record
and so we became very familiar with
their background and we went and visited
all the crime scene around around
Washington DC and that was particularly
you know some of those harrowing
research that I've ever sort of done to
actually try to be forensic about the
the characters that you were that you
were writing and sort of in examine the
crime scenes and try to discover them
from the from sort of literally from
their point of view you know where where
was the car why did they choose this
angle at what time of day but but before
that the other documents were the
primary source we started working on the
film or talking about the film late in
2010 and so a John Muhammad the older
gentleman was already had been executed
in 2009 Lee Malvo was serving
consecutive life sentences and was very
unavailable a man like really like a
moral obligation to no matter what work
with the with the with the fact and then
within those fact we were at liberty to
tell the story in and choose the angle
that we wanted into the story that that
serve our purposes but but all the you
know all the fact the construction was
had to be you know righteous when you're
dealing with with a true story one of
the big questions of course is what what
you include but the harder way to think
of that question is what what do you
leave out and how do you how do you
choose responsible emissions of material
something a major choice that we made
very early on was that we would not deal
explicitly with the fact that John
Muhammad was Muslim and and at times
used that rhetoric in his sort of
ideological language and largely I think
because that was the idea of sort of
pigeon holing the story into just a sort
of a story of Islamic extremism or
something like that was was very
unattractive there were so many more
sort of subtle layers to it that would
get completely hidden by that by that
single thought but in other cases the
omissions became essential parts of the
character you know
the choice to make Lee extremely silent
was something also that we that we came
upon very very early and it was at times
it seemed like a hard thing to commit to
especially on the page you know a
character can seem almost invisible
without dialogue which then you know
made the casting so critical but the the
idea of giving the film palpable
absences not only helped us articulate
the or let us focus on the parts of the
story that we found important but also
let us suggest this idea that maybe we
didn't know everything the producer ice
and Robin's can you know approached me
and like you know we're going to have a
casting director and so which actor do
you want in your film and I was blown
away because I thought that we're really
going to cast two people from the
streets you know that day and anyways
like so who do you want and as like well
can I pick anybody i guess so i want
isaiah washington and and yeah true you
send him a copy of dostoevsky's notes
from the underground yeah but that was
after like you know then I don't find
him and you know contacted him and he
was like you know it was lukewarm about
the whole project but so yeah I said I
have ski contingent it was like oh don't
worry it's gonna be real depressing yeah
that's a ticket yeah if it tick one
actually his his audition happened over
skype and it was instantly apparent even
even through a fuzzy yeah SD so skype
and facebook you know that that's what's
the key word is a social media yeah